RIVER IN THIS VALLEY.
>> Bill: THANK YOU.
TEXAS DEMOCRAT HENRY CUELLAR
TOURED THE BORDER YESTERDAY.
DEMOCRAT.
A COUPLE REPUBLICANS.
WELCOME BACK AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US ON OUR PROGRAM TODAY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Bill: LISTEN, I APPLAUD THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE BEEN SO
PUBLIC TRYING TO HELP THE
PEOPLE IN TEXAS AND THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN YOUR STATE.
WHY IS IT SO OBVIOUS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IGNORED
PEOPLE LIKE YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, ALL I’VE BEEN
ASKING IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND PRIOR ADMINISTRATION IS TO
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
ON THE BORDER.
WE DON’T JUST COME AND VISIT
FOR A FEW HOURS.
WE ACTUALLY LIVE THERE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH SO MUCH
EXPERIENCE, THE BORDER
SHERIFFS, POLICE CHIEFS, MAYORS
AND JUDGES AND WE KNOW HOW THE
BORDER WORKS.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS AND
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE MEXICAN
SIDE.
MOST OF THE PROPERTY OR THE
TERRITORY ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER IS CONTROLLED BY
DRUG CARTELS.
NOBODY GOES THERE AND NOBODY
CROSSES WITHOUT THEM CHARGING
THEM AND GIVING THEM THE OKAY.
>> Bill: KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH LEADING THE
RESPONSE.
IT HAS BEEN 71 DAYS SINCE SHE
WAS APPOINTED TO THAT POSITION.
BACK TO THE QUESTION.
WHY IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
IGNORING PEOPLE LIKE YOU?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, AGAIN IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE THE VICE PRESIDENT,
THE PRESIDENT TO COME VISIT THE
BORDER.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT.
BUT I GUESS THEY’LL DO IT ON
THEIR OWN TIME AND TERMS.
CERTAINLY AT THE SAME TIME
WHILE WE’RE DOING THAT I SIT ON
THE APPROPRIATIONS.
I GOT FOLKS ON THE BORDER THAT
WE SERVE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
WE HAVE A LIST OF PROPOSALS TO
ADD MORE HSI OFFICERS, THE
HOMELAND INVESTIGATORS TO GO
AFTER THE CRIMINAL DRUG CARTELS
NOT ONLY IN THE U.S. BUT GO
INTO THE FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND
GO AFTER THOSE DRUG CARTELS
BECAUSE IF YOU DON’T STOP THE
MONEY, YOU KNOW, WHAT THEY
CHARGE, 6,000 TO 8,000
DEPENDING WHO THEY ARE.
>> Bill: IT’S AN INDUSTRY.
YOU SAW THE IMAGES OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE DROWNING IN
THE RIVER THAT WERE SAVED
OVERNIGHT.
FOX CAMERAS CAUGHT THAT.
A DRONE CAUGHT A WOMAN BEING
ASSAULTED ON THE MEXICAN SIDE
OF THE BORDER.
THEN YOU HAVE THE THIS
5-YEAR-OLD BOY YESTERDAY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT CRYING OUT
FOR HELP AND PLEADING WITH
SMUGGLERS NOT TO LEAVE HIM
ALONE.
IT IS STUNNING STUFF.
WHY IS 71 DAYS ACCEPTABLE?
>> YOU KNOW, AGAIN WHAT WE’RE
SEEING AT THE BORDER IS ONLY A
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT HAPPENS TO
THESE PEOPLE.
IMAGINE THE HUNDREDS OF MILES
THAT THEY GO WITHOUT ANY U.S.
INTERVENTIONS LIKE WE HAVE AT
THE BORDER.
IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM
WHEN THEY’RE DOING THE
DANGEROUS TREK THROUGH MEXICO.
IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
PEOPLE THAT GET RAPED AND GET
ASSAULTED, INCLUDING YOUNG KIDS
AND WOMEN.
WE ARE ONLY SEEING A SNAPSHOT.
WE DON’T SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING
IN THOSE COUNTRIES.
>> Bill: WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
HENRY CUELLAR, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.